a defeat for president Mauricio Macri
was always a possibility but few even
his bitterest opponents expected it to
be quite so convincing this was only a
primary election to confirm candidates
for October's presidential elections but
voting in Argentina is obligatory and
the results sent a clear message that
the electorate is not happy with the
government's handling of the economy
president Macri acknowledged the defeat
even before the first official results
were announced
I recognize that we've had a bad
election and that obliges us from
tomorrow to redouble our efforts so that
in October we get the support we need to
continue making changes his main rival
is Alberto Fernandez cabinet chief
between 2003 and 2008 in the
left-of-centre government of nestor
kirchner thank you from the bottom of my
heart I am sure that Argentina needs to
finish with this era and build a new
history he's running with the former
President Cristina Fernandez de Kirchner
his biggest challenge is to convince the
electorate that he not she is in command
she's fighting off a number of
corruption charges from her time in
office all of which she denies perhaps
the biggest prize of the evening was the
province of Buenos Aires the country's
biggest home to more than one-third of
Argentina's total population the
governing party retained the city of
Buenos Aires but over the whole country
the primary results seem to indicate
that Argentina is ready for change after
four years of Mauricio Macri in power
it's an opportunity it's a fresh
opportunity to choose change that's what
I'm after
I'm not really an agreement with the
current government it's time for change
this makes it possible to keep
participating in our democracy we can
elect trying to improve giving people
the opportunity to reward those who do
good things and throw out those who
don't Macri took office in 2015
promising to tackle inflation and reduce
poverty but both have increased under
his watch
the people have spoken and what they
seem to be saying is that they've had
enough of Mauricio macri's IMF
sanctioned market friendly austerity
measures what they seem to prefer is the
previous governments more socially
inclusive but costly policies was likely
to now follow is a long and hard-fought
battle leading up to October's
presidential elections
Daniel Schwimmer al-jazeera one Osiris